so if you don't know the platforms not
just the algorithm that everybody likes
to talk about but even one's ability to
take advantage of all the different
creative formats when I look at around
the world what happens is the bigger you
are the more you treat social media the
way you treated television and
billboards and what's happening is it's
just all vanilla and there's not enough
output so what are companies getting
wrong they don't have enough output they
don't live under the context of
strategic content they just post for the
sake of posting they don't factor in
what is our religion which is something
we call pack platforms and culture if
you don't know that Carousel ads are
over indexing right now on Instagram
you're not going to post that a green
screen if you just post something on a
video to talk about something that's
going on in business that's fine if you
take a headline from your own article
you write an article you then take that
article and you take it into a green
screen on social and you talk over it
that format will get you three four five
times more viewers it's strategic
organic content